welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown my name is uh Mike comer and
today we have a special treat for you we
got a game it's one of the best games of
all time and this game will go over what
is a back row checkmate and what isn't a
back row checkmate and it's very very
exciting okay so a lot of games between
beginners scholastic players a lot of
them the majority of them end in back
row checkmate so you really want to make
sure to be safe with the back row
checkmate all right
so white starts out the game efore black
counters c5 this is called the Sicilian
defense white kind of place passively
here and plays Knight to c3 alright it
really doesn't attack the d4 square or
doesn't really attack too much so not
recommend it a much better move as
Knight to f3 this black plays Knight to
c6 white gets out Knight f3 now and
black plays d6 alright letting his
bishop go free here it plays out Bishop
to c4 if you're playing black in this
position would you be afraid of this
move not really because the bishop isn't
really eyeing f7 it's more like just
biting at nails here okay not really
doing much
alright so black just plays Knight to f6
and white precedes the castle black
plays d5 attacks the bishop and attacks
the pawn alright so pawn takes pawn
pawn takes back and now this Bishop is
free to go and white gets in a check
here rook to e1 check and black plays
Bishop to e7 alright if you're playing
white in this position what move would
you make alright let me ask you this
question which piece of yours is under
attack in this position the bishop very
good so so let's not even make it more
complicated than it needs to be right
the bishops under attack let's move the
bishop maybe pin the knight or something
okay all right but white makes a very
dubious move in this position he sees
another check so he plays it alright so
not very advisable
alright you never want to trade a five
point piece for a 3 point piece unless
you're going to get some kind of big
advantage alright
so white just made a mistake and an
unforced mistake at that oh wait but
that doesn't mean as black we need to
make another mistake here how should we
capture back this rook yes silence
excellent the night the night captures
back and guess what now we got another
protector of this pawn all right
unfortunately he was like oh I just it
doesn't matter just take back with a
queen it does matter cuz now the Queen
was doing something it was protecting d5
and now there's only two there's still
two attackers of d5 and only one
defender so now we can we can take take
them so he takes back with the knight
Knight takes d5 fork forking the Queen
and the knight so let's just take it
because as black now we're ahead we have
a material advantage so when we have a
material advantage we want to simplify
exchange
and then we'll just or win the game so
Bishop takes d5 okay so now black
castles alright he's gonna let him get
the double pawns if need be because he's
not afraid of exchanges in this position
so white plays out d3 letting his bishop
get in the game so now black plays
Bishop to e6 so now if we're playing
white and we want to trade who would we
trade where we trade the bishop for the
night or the bishop for the bishop even
though he probably doesn't want to trade
in this position maybe Bishop back would
be the best but let's say he just has
the trade who would we take here the
bishop are the night yes yeah take with
the take the knight because look at what
that just did to black's pawn structure
he had a really nice poster going here
one two three three connected passed
pawns three connected passed pawns to
pawn islands now by taking now he has
three pawn islands he's got an isolated
pawn over here a double isolated pawns
and then three connected okay so so now
as pawn structure is ruined okay all
right so now white gets out Bishop to f4
and black brings his rook over to d8
rook a to d8 okay so now when I play
rook a to d8 what am i attacking through
an x-ray an x-ray is where a piece is
seen through another piece to attack
another piece are square just like an
x-ray machine seen through you to see
inside okay so what is this rook
da now attacking through an x-ray you
could say the Queen yes good all right
so so now you see how this pawn is in a
pin on d3 so now we could go about
trying to attack it like pawn here or
even even funny Bishop here okay even
though that wouldn't be good we could do
it because the point can't take or else
boom it's gone
okay so there's pawns in a pin okay so
now the Queen moves off of the line to
e2 so now what is the Queen well now
what is the White Queen attacking
through an x-ray the black Queen yes all
right so now everybody see how this
bishop is now in a pin all right so now
they do a little dance here and rook F
to e 8 okay so now he protects the piece
that was in the that was being pinned to
it by the bishop okay so now it's it's
free it's fine for this bishop to move
because Queen takes them Brooke takes
okay so there's Bishop really isn't in a
pin anymore
all right so now after rook F to e 8
White's rook goes to e1 so now he's
protecting the Queen all right so now
black moves his Queen out to d7 and so
so now wipe the sides to be clever here
and it's like I don't want this bishop
to come down and take my pulling on a -
that's undefended right so I'll play the
move
b3 alright so hopefully everybody can
get this move at home and in the
audience okay because it's a really
funny move white just like played the
move b3
and thought all right my position is
solid okay but it's really not solid
because if you look at everything on the
e-file the e-file is now the action file
that's where all the action is look at
what's going on we got a rook a bishop
queen and rook all in the same lane
that's the asset action file for you so
what happens when this bishop moves if
this bishop would move anywhere then the
rook is attacking the Queen yeah so it's
a discovered attack okay so this is when
we want to get the most bang for our
buck because if this wants a special
moves White's gonna have to move the
Queen right all right
so what moves should black play in this
position knowing that once the bishop
moves right everybody can't wait hello
let's go with silent first what do you
think that's about five okay so [ __ ] it
about five so it's like wow you know the
Queen's attacked but let's say say I
move it and now you know we didn't
really make them pay that uh for this
discovery yes well unfortunately a
bishop the g4 is that what you mean all
right
all right one more try well my it's
black the move
make them pay that the rook and the
and it might correspond to White's last
move all right
he's going for his second attempt that
kind of just mocks the mocks the guy
yeah you can't take my bishop buddy then
he just plays that and you see it really
didn't make them pay and it kind of
humiliated them but they really didn't
make them pay that up for this discovery
so but if we're getting close like
really close to the answer
anybody got any guesses Stephen Bishop
captures b3 and now he's really feeling
this it's like dang it I just played b3
to stop you from getting that but nope
I'm taking it anyway okay so now why it
has to move the Queen out of the danger
so now well we could just kindly just
retreat our Bishop back with our pawn in
our hand or we could just trade which we
should and then Queen takes and now you
know we can yep just get another pawn
here okay makes sense so when you have a
discovery you really want to make your
opponent pay okay so you want to take
material or try to get a checkmate okay
we don't want to just play funny moves
like Bishop here and then it's like true
I mean you can't take the bishop but we
don't really actually gain any material
for that makes sense okay but black
actually plays the move you recommended
Bishop to g4 and now he's got a pin
going okay
so so now you would think white would
have to move the Queen right all right
but but he decided to get very very
creative so if you did not want to lose
your queen all right but you didn't want
to move your queen what's the only moot
well there's actually two moves you
could play in this position but he plays
the funnier of the two plays Bishop to
e5 all right
so he put he voluntarily puts his bishop
in a pin and and he's now he's in his
opponent's territory so what move can
black make what are we supposed to do
two pieces that are in pins attack them
excellent everybody excellent attack
them okay so what's the easiest way to
attack them yes pun f6 great but if you
were following my lectures f6 is always
the worst move on the board however I
would probably play it in this position
but it's funny if if if black ends up
losing this I bet you it's going to
because he played the move f6 okay even
though it's a good move it really
weakens his light squares leaving them
susceptible that shanks so he needed to
keep that in mind
so when you play f6 you've got to be
very very careful in in this position I
would have played enough six by the way
probably all right so white plays you
can't really play much he plays Queen to
e3 all right so now he gets out of this
pin and now if you were really smart how
would you what would you play in this
position
yes pawn takes Bishop yeah how hard is
it all right now you just play pawn to
attack the bishop and then you took it
right yeah
all right instead he decides to be funny
and take with the rock all right so so
he's like yeah I took with the rook and
I'm attacking your queen but why is that
not a good move yeah yeah our horse he
can take the rook right yeah so now
because now the knight is no longer in a
pin because the Queen's no longer in e -
so he went from doing great to not so
hot anymore okay so now he takes back
with the pawn and white goes head and
takes Queen takes d5 so now if you look
at the material we've had a little bit
of a swing White has two two power
pieces that add up to 14 points and then
he's got seven ponds so he's got 21
points Black has two major pieces that
add up to 14 points plus the bishop for
17 and now he's got one two three four
five pawns for 22
but these ponds aren't very good all
right so so we'll see what we can do
here so blacks only up by a a
technically off point right now even
though he's got a major piece sorry
so now black plays the move Queen to d4
so black is up material so he wants the
trade material and Plus this would be
very very nice of white if he took and
then he could strain up all his pawns
and and now it goes from a tough victory
for black being up that slim point even
though he's up just a point still see
how see how much easier it's gonna be to
win this endgame then well then this one
okay
so white doesn't want to do black any
favors okay
so he doesn't he plays a Queen to e7 and
gets right up there and attacks the rook
here okay so now black plays rook to f8
and he probably slammed it okay all
right so he's threatening what is he
threatening now checkmate
so a guy already sees how it's yours
threatening checkmate
does he really see how he's threatening
checkmate though that's the question
okay so if I play a four let's just say
I pass okay a four can you show me the
checkmate here yeah good or go ahead go
ahead you got the floor
you mean capture the pond all right
Queen takes have to check iolite only
has one legal move in this position it's
they go hide in the corner
all right so now
can black checkmate white notice this is
how a backward checkmate occurs white is
surrounded by his own forces so so black
has checkmate all right well you got the
floor still you know unfortunate Queen
takes rook isn't going to do the trick
because Queen comes down and takes but
he still might have checkmate and you're
looking at me on the board Queen goes
yeah Queen to the bottom boom check and
then white only has one legal move to
take and then take and checkmate okay so
a queen sacrifice to end the game
everybody see that how he is actually
threatening checkmate in this position
so you always got to be aware of these
backward checkmates because they can hit
you at any time if you're not careful
but luckily white saw it he's like I up
no problem no problem
a flex rook to e3 a very weird way to
stop a back row checkmate by leaving uh
by leaving the back row okay usually you
want more forces heading toward the back
row to stop a background check mate you
don't want to be fleeing the back row to
stop a back row checkmate
so now black gets all excited like oh
you just left the back row I got
checkmate so so what do you think black
pounded on the on the to say joy until
it's over checkmate
but it's not checkmate your Steven sees
the Queen to a1 check but it's just
check alright yeah we'll just go back so
we could do this all day if we wanted
and draw okay but obviously black even
though he's kind of mad that uh this
this then end in checkmate so now he's
mad so when you're mad what do you think
you're gonna do yeah just just take
anything is whatever I could take I'm
taking now I'm so mad all right so I
would show you and so White's like what
you just took some of my I'm gonna take
something of yours okay
so it's all good alright so now black
dude he doesn't even know what to do
anymore so it just goes Queen to be too
okay
I guess he probably tried to take the
pawn but saw hey you know it's protected
so I just stop it be - alright
so so now he left the door open and now
did I tell you how bad that move f6 is
alright trust me this is why I say it's
bad cuz why leaves you susceptible to
checks along this uh this very important
diagonal okay so what should why do to
take the lead in this game
and all stems from that careless f6 move
all right it's white to move that thinks
Steven already played on the board no he
hasn't
not as he sure looks like you did yeah
all right anybody else have any guesses
white I mean this is the winning move
you play this this move and you're gonna
probably win the game here
all right silent no you know what
Queen d5o not the best not the best but
you're on see but what did it Queen the
d5 have it said jack all right but you
want to make the most out of your checks
one you don't want to put play checks
where obviously your pieces get taken
but you want to be doing forks forks
basically double attack so you want to
be attacking the king and other pieces
so so look at this bishop he's an
undefended piece in your territory right
right so is there any way that one of
our pieces could attack the king and
this Bishop simultaneously Queen to c4
check okay good much better than Queen
to d5 check all right so now so now
let's say he played yeah you could move
his Bishop the block and then we could
just take with Jack
but he decides to play rook to f7 you
went Arg you don't want to take his
bishop well what do you think what do
you think so so I kind of say hey just
take the bishop my Michaels saying so
it's over right
good very good Michael he found the
checkmate yeah you don't want to take a
three-point piece when you can checkmate
the billion dollar piece okay and yeah
game's over
all right so that was very exciting now
you know what a backroad checkmate is
and how to try to avoid them but you
really you really don't want to do what
he did where he actually leaves the back
row to stop the back row checkmate
although it worked
I'll give it the triple Ganim that it
did work but uh it's very very risky
okay so we have another game this is oh
no oh no I find it alright alright
here's the game this is a game between
uh Justin Hall and our Scholastica
coordinator Matt Barrett this is another
great one all right so so white starts
out efore and black plays d5 white plays
Knight f3 black plays Knight to c6
alright now now Jocelyn goes head and
puts his Bishop on b5 this is called the
Roy Lopez okay so black plays a6 now if
I was playing the word Lopez it's white
I would take this and give my opponent
double pawns
double pawn
all right the whole point of this is
well he's got double pawns obviously and
then eventually we'll get into an
endgame where I have these four pawns to
his three and I can create a a passed
pawn and then he's got these four pawns
to my three and he can't create a passed
pawn because they is double and weak
okay but instead Justin plays another
variation of the wari Lopez not
recommended
Bishop to a4 so he is the same black you
can play b5 for free I'll go here and
then you know he could play Knight to a5
and and get the bishop to already where
he could just not family develop two
however he wants to do it all right so
so after Bishop to a4 black decides not
to get into this b5 he just decides I'm
just gonna develop normal Knight f6 all
right white gets castle and so now black
wants to get cast sold he decides to
just play Bishop to e7 instead of going
to c5 rook to e1 protects the pawn and
now black decides okay I'll play b5 why
not and now the bishop goes to be three
so now black plays d6 see black should
have really played as Bishop to c5
instead of the e7 right because now this
Bishop is trapped not very good nowhere
to go nowhere to go all right so it kind
of box himself in there but now white
decides to play d4 so black doesn't want
to take here because he's hoping that
after he makes a move like castle
obviously that he'll help him out he'll
do own favor but as I said before
you know now as bishop can go free you
don't want to be doing your opponents
any favors in the game of chess okay all
right so so you see how taking even
though it's pawn for pawn it would be a
weak move because it would be allowing
his piece to begin mobile all right so
you want to make sure when you're doing
exchanges that you're getting some kind
of advantage out of them and not helping
out your opponent all right so it's a
white plays c3 alright he's like oh wait
you take and then you make my pawns good
okay but black sees that and he's like
I'm gonna have no part of that either
what do you think black plays in this
position if you had to guess anybody
have any guesses so we obviously see we
don't want to do any pawn trades we
probably want to get one of our pieces
off the back row right so maybe a Bishop
to g4 a pin okay so now white decides
all right and up with the exchange is
you don't want to find d5 I'm attacking
you all right
so now this is a very interesting
position here this is not one you see
too often
all right so d5 I just attacked the
knight right so who do you think we
should move as black the knight right
okay good we should move the knight
Knight to a5 attacks the bishop what do
you think he would do you play Bishop
the c2 all right and if we ever try to
get our knight down here
he'll play b3 and our Knight we'll just
have to retreat all right so we want to
think ahead we don't want to be like oh
wow attack is his bishop well just think
for a second don't play hope just be
like hey he's not gonna really let me
just take Knight takes bishop he's gonna
retreat it okay
Knight to a7 pretty bad we actually want
to just go all the way back to b8 and
now we don't want to just pour our back
on b8 and say well he's just back home
oh well nothing I can do we want to be
having plans okay so then we could play
our Knight here and then the c5 and then
he's attacking the bishop and the pawn
okay so there would be a decent plan for
black and so he sees it because at this
time he was almost a chess expert he is
now so he sees hey I'll put my knight on
b8 and then I'll get a plane going okay
so Justin's just putting his pieces off
the back row and he's gotten really no
idea why okay Knight B to D to Knight B
to d7 is I'll go to f1 Knight f1 but
he's got a plan with it I mean it's a
simple plan and the plan that really
shouldn't work when he basically wants
to put his knight so night to c5 attacks
the Bishop Bishop back to c2 and now
black decides he doesn't want to get
back row checkmated here all right but
let's just say a black passes okay all
right let's just pretend okay planes
work to a7 what do you think whites
moves or white move is gonna be and it's
kind of orchestrated out what are these
are gone I mean if you look at if you
look at his last two moves it's been
Knight B to d2
Knight to f1 where do you think this
nights going
III to attack the bishop and then we can
just play Bishop here right sound good
whoa what one one player doesn't like it
at all
well we legally could play midgets at
age five but but by playing the move g6
here to stop the back row checkmate it's
kind of weird because now if we play
Knight to e3 and we put our bishop back
there that's kind of scary
because he can try to h3 and then g4
okay so kind of weird move g6 alright
and now let's just say we don't play
Knight to e3 here what do you think is
kind of a natural move when somebody
plays g6 in this position forget the
night idea right now what do you think
we should play here yeah Bishop to h6
looks very good okay
and now our Bishop is attacking the rook
and he's has to play rook to e8 okay and
now we can go ahead and play Knight to
III okay alright but but instead he
plays he I think he just goes head with
his idea of night to e3 and it blocks in
his Bishop that's another reason that
Bishop move what was necessary Bishop to
h6 so night to e3 and black decides to
play a five here
alright so so obviously he's gonna take
here and Knight takes so the reason why
he exchanged there is now he doesn't
have to worry about the pin anymore all
right
so white doesn't want to hit so so you
see now if this Knight moves anywhere
the knight is under attack here Queen
takes g4 okay but there's no really good
place for him to go he can't play Knight
takes Knight because this night
could then come down and take him back
so he's got this x-ray going but he
decides to play h3 here so obviously
when he plays h3 he's gonna have to move
the knight right back to f6 so he's like
well I played h3 you know go away but
it's also taken away any kind of cool
move he wanted to do like he might have
been it what my mayor wanted to play
Knight to d4 it's sometimes I know
obviously it takes here but you take
back and now you're attacking two
knights okay so you eliminate all kind
of tricks you can do okay but hey he
wanted he wanted that night out of there
so h3 so now he's like well I'm not
gonna get back rope checkmated either
all right look at me okay so that's
great okay so Knight f6 so once again he
could do the move up Peter recommended
Bishop h6 right rook to e8 okay cuz
that's the only place
plaque and go to work the EA right all
right but instead he holds it off and
plays b4 okay attacks the night so he
takes he takes back and now he swings
his Knight to a4 so he's threatening
Knight to c3 and all kinds of good
things okay so white decides to play
Queen to d3 in this position so you have
to ask yourself why did he play Queen to
d3 to attack the pawn so so that's where
you knew it so let's just protect it
okay can't be any easier than that Queen
to d7 and now white finally decides I'm
gonna attack this now but because he
waited so long now does this rook have
to go to e8 no right King go wherever he
wants
and so he missed a free move basically
alright so so now Brooke F goes to the C
file instead of being stuck on e85 he
wanted if he would have played this
about five moves earlier see the
position would be like this
and it would be white to move here and
he could do anything he wants or I don't
know well everybody would want to do
maybe a three or something and then he
would have to play here and that would
be White's move alright but see in this
position when he plays Bishop h6 now
rook here and now it's a white to move
instead again two moves will get only
one okay so you really want to take
advantage you know when you see a good
move just play it and and don't wait
because it could be too late now it's
not even that great of a move all right
so now rook F to see a he decides I'm
gonna take the guy how should black take
back Jerry take back with the rook or
with the pawn the rook right this is we
have an open file on the a file we don't
want to give that up for nothing okay
and now we can start piling up on this
on this a file and piling up on there
very good okay so don't clog up your
files okay so now he plays his rook over
to cc1 and that's a big oversight okay
so just because so now what should black
play obviously black didn't see it or
white didn't see this move in the game
what move that we have Steven sees it it
looks like adjourn do you see it yeah
rook takes B for it okay so this is what
Justin failed to see in the game all
right look
so Bishop takes Knight
rook takes okay so he just thought wow
he's just taking my piece back big deal
okay so so just because he was taking
something didn't mean he didn't want to
be on that square for other reasons
besides just capturing so so it's an
oversight you see a lot where okay he
just took back you've got to see when
they capture you back to see Wow what is
what is that piece doing you know so
good on that square that he just took
back so he has other reasons besides
just taking back to wanting to be on a
four and it's to attack the pawn so then
boom he just lost the pawn okay but it's
okay he's just down upon he can uh you
can try to recover here so he brings his
knife back to d2 black plays c6 attacks
the pawn here alright white decides
attack the rook a3 rook the a4 now he's
like I'm gonna take rook takes c6 and
now Justin thinks he sees a tactic here
he calculates this all the way out and
thinks I'm gonna have back row checkmate
at the end of it because he sees this
Bishop controlling g7 and f8
okay so he thinks see it in this well he
thinks he's got checkmate okay because
the King can't can't flee okay so so he
decides to take Queen takes d5 okay
alright so so look at what the Queen's
in the same lands the rook the Queen the
rook the Queen so if this work moves
right the Queen's are lined up right the
Queen's are lined up against each other
so
what would you want to say as black when
you move the rook so then you could
check good alright you want to say check
ok so there's only one check you can do
with the rook and Justin just smile and
he's like yeah you're falling right into
my plan
you're falling right into my plan and so
when Matt comes up and takes oh he's
just smiling so so big he's like I can't
believe you fell for it
so he's like check alright so so why did
Justin go from smiling ear-to-ear to be
like oh my god
I just lost the game right he was
thinking he's just gonna play his Queen
back and then he's going to take and the
game's over checkmate but he failed to
realize at the check Justin's got this
neat little move Knight to e8 and now
he's done a lot of material and and they
just just gets up and they say God game
over okay so so when you do checkmates
background check mates you got to make
sure that they really are back row
checkmates and because you think to see
something like okay that's definitely a
mate but you got to be really really
precise about it and don't let them
block the checkmates a great book that's
very recommended that we actually sell
at the club is our Bobby Fischer teaches
chess it's a great book it's a quick
read
there's no notation on it it's just
simple yes-or-no questions like is this
a checkmate as it's not a checkmate they
go through a lot of a back road
checkmates and other cool checkmates
very recommended for you to purchase